all right well I'm gonna go ahead and
get started today I want to thank you
for hanging on to the very last session
of NDC London I know that you know it's
Friday and it's time for happy hour and
we got PubCon coming up so you could
have just bailed and gone to the pub
next door but I hear it's a you Kipp pub
and nobody wants to hang out with you
Kipp politicians I don't think so
thank you instead for coming here today
I want to talk about get the git version
control system of course which I suspect
you're all using is there anybody who's
not using it it's using something else
oh my god what are you using all right
only SVN no get it all all right well I
want to make you thankful for using some
version then no just kidding but I do
want to talk about some of the weirder
intricacies and idiosyncrasies of of get
before I do I want to introduce myself
really quickly I've never spoken at NDC
London I've spoken to other NDC
conferences I suspect you know a lot of
you don't know who I am my name is
Everett Thompson I'm a program manager
at Microsoft I work on Azure DevOps
if you don't know what Azure DevOps is
it's a suite of products for the
software development lifecycle
we've got Azure boards that help you
plan your software project as your repos
which store get or T FEC sorry no
subversion repositories to store your
code and then Azure pipelines to build
that code and deploy it into production
and I focus primarily on the CI CD side
so azure pipelines and the get side and
I've been doing version control for a
really long time I've been building dev
tools for years and years and years I
was building version control systems
before it get was a thing so a lot of
when I look at version control it's
through that lens a little bit I don't
only do developer tools though I do have
a life outside of work and that is also
subsumed by
developer tools so if you're interested
in dev tools and I hope you are because
you're here on Friday happy hour instead
of drinking I've got a newsletter
developer tools weekly which is
interesting stuff I hope and a podcast
about get it's called all things get so
I end up talking a lot about get as you
can kind of imagine and one of the the
talks I often give is about get
internals like how git works at a low
level because if you've used git you
might know that it's a little bit hard
to use at a high level like the command
line is weird
right using git is frustrating sometimes
and understanding how git works helps
alleviate a little bit of that
frustration because you can kind of
understand what it is that you want to
do from gits standpoint from the object
model standpoint and then you can figure
out what command you need to run to
actually make that happen whereas if you
don't understand what's going on at all
then you might not know how to map that
to a command and you may just be lost
and you may end up deleting your repo
and re cloning it and that's no good
nobody wants to do that so I often talk
about get internals and if you've heard
this talk about get internals from me or
from anybody else
you might think that git is this really
well designed system and in many ways it
is right I'm not going to give the whole
get internals talk but I will mention
that get is a directed acyclic graph and
really what it does is it has pointers
and everything's really nice and
beautiful you have this lovely graph of
commits and you have branches pointing
to them and head is a branch that points
to the branch you're on and this is
really elegant from a you know software
development standpoint from a design
standpoint it's really great I really
love it and if you look a little deeper
then you can look at how the the trees
are made up right so you take a file
it's called a blob and get parlance and
that file gets hashed and it gets stuck
into a tree and that's the
the hierarchy of your repository and
that gets hashed and that gets stuck
into a commit and that that gets hashed
and it points to other commits and so
what this is is called a Merkel tree and
when it's put into the dag like we just
saw that's called a Merkel dag and you
don't necessarily need to know any of
this I'm just you know talking because
I'm not gonna give this talk about how
beautiful the get internals are instead
I'm gonna tell you how git is scary this
time so if you do want to know this
stuff it's great there's a pointer at
the end I can point you to other talks
what I want to do is step up a level and
instead of talking about these beautiful
internals and the theoretical way that
get is supposed to work let's talk about
the way it actually works on a day to
day basis and where it causes problems
and I can't not think about get and
problems and not immediately think about
line endings how many of you use Windows
yeah quite a few how many of you have
run into some weird problem on git where
all of a sudden is telling you a files
change that you've never touched before
yes those are line endings so really
quickly let's take a file simple file
it's got two lines in it hello comma
world and I've got over here on the left
am i right you are left I've opened up a
file on UNIX I've opened up the VI
editor and I've typed capital h-e-l-l-o
comma I've hit the enter key capital W
Oh rld exclamation point hit the enter
key again save the file no problem right
really simple over here on the right
hand side I've done the same thing in
Windows with notepad but of course I
don't get the same file I suspect many
of you know this I'm sorry to be very
elementary but I just want to you know
start from the basics these aren't the
same thing
why aren't they the same file because
UNIX uses a different way to store
the fact that I've got a new line then
Windows does on UNIX I get one character
it's called a new line
it's ASCII ten on Windows I've got two
characters a carriage return and a line
feed ASCII 13 followed by ASCII 10 so
sometimes you'll see funny characters at
the end of a file when you look at it on
UNIX when it was made on Windows because
it's got that extra character that extra
carriage return where did this come from
well you can go way way back and look at
this lovely device that existed before
we had these nice LCD screens before we
had CRTs even we had teletypes and this
is an actual teletype this is the from
the teletype corporation of Skokie
Illinois not too far from where I grew
up it's right outside of Chicago the
teletype this is an ASR 33 and way back
in the day if you had a CPM machine you
know the precursor to Doss if you had a
CPM machine and you wanted to talk to a
teletype you had to tell it exactly what
to do you had to tell it exactly what
characters to put on that piece of paper
right it's like a typewriter but with a
serial port on it and so if you wanted
to print to the user from a computer
program hello world you would send
capital h-e-l-l-o comma and then if you
wanted to send that newline you had to
instruct the teletype what to do you had
to say hey now that the printheads over
here having written hello comma you need
to get back over there to the beginning
of the next line so I want you to return
I want the carriage to return hence the
name carriage return and once it is over
there you need to advance the paper you
need to feed the paper you need to do a
line feed
hence carriage return line feed and to
be completely honest this thing is very
stupid you probably also had to say hey
while you're doing that don't print
anything else because if you just said
hey do that
turn start sending the the printhead
that way
now also start typing world it would you
know start typing world as it's going
backwards so you'd kind of get world in
the middle of everything so incredibly
stupid so as a programmer if you wanted
to talk to this thing you had to be very
very careful you had to know exactly
what it was doing
cuz that teletype ASR 33 is different
than you know an IBM teletype is
different than somebody else's now UNIX
on the other hand looked at this problem
and said holy crap there's a lot of
teletypes and I don't want to have to
worry about them so they built a device
driver yes not like a video driver but a
device driver for teletypes so instead
of as a UNIX programmer having to say
syn the the printhead back that way
advance the paper this many rows and you
know why don't you wait a minute so that
I can let that actually happened because
you don't know how long to wait how long
does it take the printhead to get back
on an ASR 33 it might be different than
a fast IBM printer so in UNIX you have a
device driver for this you send a
newline character to Unix you print it
to the screen or you know to the tty
UNIX intercepts that knows I've got an
ASR 33 connected I know how to advance
the lines on that so very early device
drivers to take care of this for you and
that is why UNIX uses a single character
okay let's face it there device driver
could have used two characters and saved
us all a buttload of trouble but you
know let's pretend that this nice
fiction but despite that despite the
fact that Windows grew up out of CPM
from CPM to Doss to Windows and still
uses those two characters and UNIX did
not it uses that one before again when
we were building version control systems
we didn't care about what new lines you
used Team Foundation version control
takes the bytes that you give it and
puts it in the database and get sorry
CVS subversion take the bytes that you
give it and put it into the database by
and large again it is really the first
version control system that
recive li expects you to be cognizant of
line endings and will kind of give you
the middle finger if you get it wrong if
you don't know this guy this is Linus
Torvalds Linus built the Linux kernel
and he built get to handle the Linux
kernel and so realistically a lot of the
people who are involved in get in the
early days we're also billing the Linux
kernel so you take a bunch of Linux
hackers you tell them to build a version
control system and then somebody shows
up and says hey things are weird on
Windows well that's how we got into this
mess right so if you actually go and
look at the git source code you'll see
some see but you'll also see things like
shell scripts and Perl and a bunch of
things that weren't really made to think
about lines that didn't have a UNIX
style line separator in them so
fundamentally the way that the get
community solved that was not you know
hey let's let's think about this problem
let's devise a good solution it was well
we're here to build the Linux kernel and
let's make it work for everybody else
so what get ended up with was this
setting called cord Auto crlf how many
how many people set cord out Auto crlf
how many people have said it correctly
right right I'll put my hand down
because I'm not even sure at this point
fundamentally the idea behind cord on
auto crlf is that get wants unix-style
line endings get will get unix-style
line endings no matter what you have on
disk so it will take your lovely window
style line endings on your Windows
computer and it will do its thing and in
the repository you will actually get
UNIX tile line endings that it can cope
with because early versions of get again
shell scripts Perl C and it would do
things like okay well if you want to do
a rebase and you
or the files that you're rebasing don't
have unique style line endings I don't
know what to do everything's a conflict
right because I've got these weird
carriage returns in the midst of them
and if you go and look on Stack Overflow
if you read the pro get book if you read
any guidance it will all tell you to set
core dot Auto crlf because that's what
get once that's what get expects to be a
good unix program right and so what
happens when you have court out on OCR
left set is you have some file contents
and over here they've got a care to turn
in a new line there in Windows style
format and what we think of what we
talked about so when I give that get
internals talk what we always say is you
run git add git takes your file contents
hashes it puts it in the object database
super simple and we move on that's a lie
I'm sorry that I lied to you if you've
seen my talk before I apologize what
actually happens is we check is cornado
crlf set so on a UNIX machine it won't
be set at all it's default is false if
you are on a Windows machine and you set
court Auto crlf equals false then that
fiction I gave you is true and life is
simple goes right into the object
database no problem at all if it is set
to true what happens is get runs what's
called the crlf filter so it takes your
file on disk in Windows format cleans it
no note that little judgment that get
has inserted it cleans your file takes
the clean version and puts that in the
object database now anybody who shares
your repository who is on a UNIX
computer they just get that file just in
that UNIX contents just the way they
like it you you have to deal with the
filtered version that's no problem
when you run git checkout the same thing
happens we like to pretend that we just
pull it right out of the object database
put it right on disk super simple super
straightforward look how easy a system
get is in reality Auto C our left is in
the mix
and you windows users you look at auto
crlf and when it's true we run the
smudge filter we take that nice clean
content we smudge it and we put it on
disk in Windows format and everything's
happy right absolutely
there is no problem I don't understand
what the problem is except everybody who
raised their hand and said yeah
sometimes get tells me I've made changes
that I haven't I don't know what on
earth is going on let's take a look so
here I have there we go here I have a
git repository let me zoom in a bit and
you know what I'm going to do I have a
nice thing prepared hide that let me
just get some things out of the way
there we go great so I'm gonna clone a
repository from github put it right here
on this and what I'm gonna do I'm
actually on a Mac it turns out Mac's can
have the auto CRLs setting as well who
knew so I'm gonna emulate being on a
Windows machine and setting Chordata
crlf equals true when I clone this
repository there we go
nice and fast all I got is just a couple
of text files write a hello world and
then you know a couple others if I run
get status of course nothing has changed
right I haven't touched a thing why
would get status tell me that that
anything had changed so here's the trick
about that let's look at what is
actually on disk and again I set for
doubt Auto see our left equals true so
if I actually look at the file content
so I'm gonna use hex dump and actually
look at what's going on in here I'll
move that up so everybody in the back
and see hello comma and then
oh there's two characters they're 0d 0a
13 10 CR LF so i've got windows style
line endings on disk
great
and that's fine because again what we've
done is we've run this filter we've
taken contents out of the repository
that had unix-style line endings on them
put them on disk with window style line
endings so if I look into the repository
if I look at the actual contents that
are stored in the object database I'll
see you next I'll line endings right
sorry wrong command so I want an ls3
head this will actually show me the
actual contents of the repository this
is my files this is the hash right 40
character hash and so I can take one of
those hashes and actually look right in
the object database let's take a look at
this hello text hello world text see so
if I run cat file I get the contents if
I run cat file and pipe that to hex dump
I can see exactly the bytes on disk and
again I'll scroll it up a bit and Oh No
I've got crlf but that's not the
contract that I made with git I cloned
this repository I've set Auto crlf
equals true and somebody else has
checked in crlf line endings hmm and I
said that I've violated a contract with
git because in fact I do have a contract
with git so every time I run get status
what I should have happen is that it
looks at the contents on disk runs that
crlf filter ends up with UNIX style line
endings and compares it to what's in the
repository to know if I've changed
something or not so in theory when I run
gets status actually it should tell me
that everything has changed
but it's not it's telling me that
nothing has changed well that's kind of
weird and it explains why only some of
you raise your hands and some of you
kind of half-heartedly well why does
this happen sometimes where git is
confused about the line endings that I
actually have going on in my application
what's going on is you have encountered
the cache aka the index aka the staging
area we talked about this
beautiful piece of art and get as if it
is what we say about the index is that
it's the next commit to exist on disk
when you were in get add you put things
into the staging area you have staged
your changes right sometimes when you
edit a file it'll say changes you know
not Stage four commit you run get add
now there
stage 4 commit now if you go edit that
file again now you've got stage changes
and on stage changes so that's what's
going on here is the index contains the
things that you will commit the next
time you run git commit well it's got a
bunch of names if you look it up in the
documentation it's the index it's the
staging area and sometimes it's the
cache and we almost never talk about
what it means for this data structure to
be the cache well let's take a look at
what's actually going on here I can
inspect the cache running get LS files -
- stage and this shows me the staging
part of the cache ie what's about to be
committed so if I run git commit it will
commit these contents and in fact that's
identical to what is already there so it
won't actually do anything at all I can
also run git LS files - - to Bach and
now it spits a ton of extra information
like C time and downtime and dev and I
know and UID and GID and blah blah blah
what on earth is going on here this is
stuff that doesn't get checked in this
there is no data structure when you run
git clone that gives you this
information this is the the caching part
of the index
so when get checks files out on disk
when it writes files in your working
directory it updates this information
the C time is the creation time modify
the modification time of the files that
it has put on disk not the time that it
was changed in the repository when you
checked it out the size of the file the
UID and GID
so it updates this whenever it writes a
file so that it knows that it wrote the
file so it puts the file on disk it says
hey here's when I did it now I never
have to look at it again because I know
you haven't touched the file it's only
when you go start changing the file that
you've invalidated the cache and it has
to go and look at what you've done to
find out if you change something or not
so let's get rid of that cash I can get
RM - our - - cached star so usually get
RM will remove files from your
repository I don't want to remove the
files I just want to remove the cached
information I want to remove them from
the index okay now if I run get add dot
it'll put them right back on disk and
now if I run get status everything is
modified because I've been validated the
cache now get looks at the files on disk
and it says hey everything's different
right because it's pulling the data off
disk applying that crlf filter and
comparing it to what's in the repository
see our left filter turns it into eunuch
style line endings what's in the
repository has windows style lined
endings so these files are in fact
different if I run git diff - - cached
it'll tell me how and the answer is
they're not get is telling me that I've
changed all these files with nothing at
all
because of course it's just a bunch of
line ending changes oh it is terrible
and this can happen to absolutely
anybody this is the path that get takes
you down get when you install it on
Windows get for window has this nice
installer and it takes you through it
where do you want to install it next you
know what did things do you want to
enable next do you want auto updates
next and you just keep clicking next and
one of those questions is how do you
want to set up Cortado to see our level
and even if you're not in the habit of
just install it already clicking next if
you stop to read it it's going to ask
you do you want to set it up
so that you know it's it's a page of
text that doesn't make any sense
right I get to this I've ridden see our
left code I've built translators I built
these smudge and clean filters and I get
to this question and I'm like god I
don't know
so how then should someone who's never
used yet be expected to get this right
I'm sorry the gate community has failed
you all here I have there's there's no
easy way to put it because even so let's
take a look at my repository this is an
actual production repository that I use
it's called Lib get to it is the get
implementation that github uses and
Microsoft uses in get lab and bitbucket
get crackin all sorts of tools are built
on top of this repository we're supposed
to get this right right so why run git
status I've not changed a thing let me
check out a commit a branch from about
two weeks ago when we screwed something
up and yeah I really screwed something
up now all of a sudden it works yeah
okay well in theory this was supposed to
say that you know I had a file changed
as soon as I switched branches and yet I
apparently to not let me make sure I did
the right thing yeah okay well indeed
these sorts of problems are very wily
aren't they yeah okay well we'll just
pretend that that actually had a phantom
failure won't weak the demo gods are not
nice in any case let's pop back to our
original repository that has all of
these changes in it right so the the
solution to this problem is not actually
cordon Auto crlf despite the fact that
you've read it in books you've read it
on Stack Overflow
you've read it and surely heard it from
people like me
Cortado CLF is not the solution at least
it's not the only solution to
this problem let's let's back these
changes out real quick and what we
actually want to do is set up what's
called a git attributes file why is core
da da da Ciara left the right solution
and get attributes or is the wrong
solution and get attributes is the right
one core not Auto crlf is a setting that
you set on your computer it does not get
checked into the repository right we set
it here locally but that didn't actually
match the reality of the repository that
we cloned the repository that we cloned
had window style line endings which I
will posit is fine but we had Cortana
CRLs set to tell git that the repository
we cloned had unix-style line endings
and that is a problem so what we need to
actually do is check in the
configuration with the contents right if
we have Windows style line annex in the
repository that's fine as long as we
tell everybody cloning the repository
that that's the case
same with UNIX timeline innings and so
that's where this file called get
attributes comes in with a good
attributes file you can check in the
configuration of your line endings into
the repository and so what I would
encourage you all to do in all of your
repositories is set it up with star text
equals Auto this is the moral equivalent
of cordon Auto crlf equals true this
says put files in my repository as with
UNIX line endings and on a Windows
machine check them out with window style
line endings so in other words on every
computer give me my native line index I
think that's a perfectly reasonable
solution there are other options here
you can say hey just never touch
anything get just put the contents right
in the repository always give me what I
check in I think that's fine too the
important thing is it
needs to be configured here okay so let
me save this file and now when I run get
status it'll tell me everything changed
right indeed it does not it just tells
me how I get attributes file change
because again the cache is kicking in
here and it's telling us that it's put
these files on disk it knows that we
haven't touched them therefore nothing
could have changed despite the fact that
we've updated the line ending
configuration well in that case there is
a second step that is necessary we get
it up at the top for everybody in the
back get ad - - renormalize dot and this
is it you update your good attributes
file you run this command and mmm okay
I'm not gonna lie many of your crlf
problems will go away when you do this
if I run get status after that it will
tell me all the things that have changed
it's updated all of those files and if I
run get diff - - cached to show me what
is staged its updated the line of things
but this is the last time that that will
happen so let me also get add my get
attributes file and check that in
great and now of course I have to
actually push this change so I will push
it up to my github account and great all
of my problems are solved right oh if it
were only so easy let me pop over to my
github account and the problem is that I
actually have some pull requests open
and the pull requests of course are open
against the old contents of the
repository and now I have conflicts
I have conflicts because I've made a
change but I've also updated the end of
every single line so every pull request
I have now has conflicts in it and this
I admit is really painful however there
is thankfully a really easy way to get
yourself out of this so you know you
could of course do sometimes it's called
flag day where all of a sudden
everything in the repository changes and
everybody has to throw it away and clone
and start over that's certainly one
option and if you're a one-person team
that's a reasonable one if you're any
more than that that gets old really
quick so let's say I'm one of these pull
request authors how do I get myself out
of this situation well let me check out
one of these branches
and what are the changes that I'm
bringing in well again let me bring that
up top for the for everybody in the back
so what I've changed is I've changed the
end of the line from a period to an
exclamation point and yet is actually so
deficient about line endings that it is
still showing me this even though the
line ending didn't change on this pull
request think you get again that's why
that's why normalizing line endings
really is helpful forget it's not great
at this it really did come out of Unix
but what I can do is I can run git merge
master and this is going to conflict
right we've we've made all those changes
on master we changed every line of every
file it will definitely conflict so that
is not enough if I am the pull request
author what I actually need to do is
give merge a special flag so just like
we ran add dash dash renormalize I can
merge with renormalization and so for
any of my pull requests all I have to do
is grab that new master and get merge -
dad sorry - ex renormalize I've got this
all written down you don't have to
memorize any of this I'll point you to
it at the end so what does this do - ex
passes a flag to the merge strategy
telling it hey instead of just doing the
merge simply fix up the line endings
first everything's changed there voila
it just takes me right to the editor
telling me that I've merged and so what
actually happened it brought on the line
ending fix ups as well as the change so
now I can just push that back to my pull
request branch pop back over in github
hit reload I don't even have to hit
reload it even new and now that pull
request is green
so it is annoying
I concede you might think that you don't
want to go through this pain however I
really think that you know this is a rip
the band-aid off situation where you
update the line endings once and for all
yes you'll have to touch the old pull
requests but it's a very straightforward
process and after that you should not
see any more of these sort of phantom I
call them phantom changes where all of a
sudden it tells you that you have made a
change but you in fact happens all right
let's put line endings aside for just a
minute
one of the things that I think is really
interesting about merge is something
that I see every time I do a merge
almost every time I run it it says merge
made by the recursive strategy I think a
lot of you have probably seen this too
what does that even mean it's of me I
had to actually write merge code before
I actually understood what that meant
and I think it's fascinating so I want
to share that with you really quickly so
there we go so the idea behind merge is
is pretty straightforward the when I
talk about get internals what I like to
say is that when you merge one branch
into another let's say we're merging the
branch called branch because I'm very
unoriginal when it comes to names into
this branch called master what happens
well we do what's called a three-way
merge and in this is this is true not
just in yet this is true in pretty much
every version control system the idea is
that you find the common ancestor you
find out where the last time a merge
took place between two branches or where
they forked off originally and and yet
it's really easy because we've got this
nice graph that represents the way
change has happened we started out with
a commit we made another commit and then
we branched off of that and we ended up
with this branch called branch master
kept going so it's really easy to figure
out where that common ancestor is it's
right there git makes this really stupid
straightforward obviously in a in a more
complicated repository this gets a
little bit harder but this is nothing
like the difficulty in say team
foundation version control or subversion
where you've got to track every branch
and merge operation and do some math to
figure out where you're at and honestly
sometimes get it wrong git doesn't get
this wrong very often but that
identifies the way trees get merged and
then you take files and you do the same
thing right so you look at let's say a
common ancestor it has six files in it
ABCDE and F and what you want to do is
basically look at each of these files in
each of the branches that you're merging
and figure out how things have changed
right so this shows my changes let me
give you some colors so it's not quite
so terrible to try to read right so in
our common ancestor a dot text totally
unchanged what happens in the merge well
it doesn't matter we take any of those
they're all the
so we retake the file you know often
when you do emerge most of your files
don't change that's that's very true but
when you do change a file on just one
side and get calls it the ours side
that's the branch that you're on when
you run git merge kind of a weird
terminology but whatever it works so if
you change the ours side from the common
ancestor and you don't touch the other
branch well we just take that right
that's you know I've edited a file I run
git merge now the file I changed gets
into master no problem
see Tex didn't change D not checks only
changed on one side so we preserve that
in the merge we don't want to obliterate
anybody else's changes of course the
tricky bits of course come in when we've
changed a file on both sides so we need
to we'll put a pin in that we need to
figure out what to do when we've changed
a file on both branches and you know if
even if it's a delete on only one side
that doesn't matter that's not a
conflict if you've deleted it and
changed it that's a conflict so the
tricky bit here is what happens when
I've changed a file in both places and
what we really do is the same thing only
for the contents of a file so for this
file I've got ten lines in my branch I
change line two and three in their
branch they change line seven and eight
well just like before I can just take
those changes in and get all of the
contents from both changes again the
tricky part comes when I actually change
the same set of lines and unlike when
you've got working with files it doesn't
go character by character and try to
figure out you know what you've changed
in each line that would be madness I
think for the most part it just kind of
gives up and says well if you've changed
line five and six in one branch line
five and six in another branch you've
got a conflict right I'm sure you're
used to seeing all of this we saw it
just a minute ago when we changed all
the line endings and what get does is it
dumps out a file with all these arrows
in it all the arrows for your side
and then below that a bunch of equal
signs all the arrows for the theirs side
right so we've saw just a minute ago
what happens when you do all of these
changes and end up with just line ending
changes in the midst of what you're
doing we kind of call that around where
I am merge hell right and the way to get
out of that is through the renormalized
flag which we saw and again that's a
flag to the recursive strategy there we
go right so what on earth does that even
mean well it's it's a way to ideally
make things a little bit better right so
what I want to do here is create some
conflicts actually let me pop back to
this branch here so hello dot text I'm
gonna make this a question mark here
run add and commit and go back to master
make a different change bring in more
exclamation points
and when I run git merge branch of
course it tells me I have a conflict
because I changed a lot the same line in
both right and it gives me again all of
those arrows right so one of the things
that I can do here is get a little bit
more information about what's going on
so let me abort this merge I'm gonna
start over but before I do I want to set
this flag
it's called merge conflict style and so
instead of drawing those arrows and the
equal sign and the other arrows giving
you the side that one side change
decides that the other side changed this
will give you a little more insight into
how they changed by showing you that
common ancestor so it'll show you the
contents that they were before anybody
changed anything and that can give you a
little more insight into how you've made
changes and how the other side is made
changes because sometimes that's really
obvious sometimes it's not so I can set
it to what's called dip 3 meaning bring
in the all three sides of the merge and
if I run git merge branch again still
get a conflict of course but now I get
more information so I've got head and
I've got my side got the branch that I'm
merging in and that's question mark and
that tells me that it used to be a
period so I get a little bit more
information but it also says merged
common ancestors so it's not the common
ancestors it's actually the quote
unquote or common ancestor rather it's
the quote unquote merged common
ancestors and that is where the
recursive bit of git merge recursive
comes in so let me throw that away
done with that don't care about that
anymore I've got this branch or this
repository right here called recursive
and if I run git log and turn on the
graph mode to get log which I think is a
great bit of functionality if you've
never done it sorry let me actually do
that and then show all branches so this
ASCII art is a bit on the deficient side
but you can kind of see that this graph
is a little weird so what I'm doing is
one of my branches goes off another
branch goes off and they actually got
merged back together so what's called a
criss cross merge and this is the point
at which I throw this away and I start
looking at a real tool Tower is a good
one and I can look at history in Tower
so let me open up that repository let me
look at my history and I can zoom in a
bit this makes it a little bit easier to
see what happened again I've got this
branch here merging back into that one
and then this branch merges into that
one they merge into each other so
somebody has checked out branch run git
run merge master so we just checked out
nasara and get merge branch and that's
where we're at so everybody has each
other's changes in a perfect world that
should be very straightforward because
they've resolved the merge conflicts
that arose when they merged into each
other so now if I'm in this branch and I
let's actually do this so git gives you
a command again we looked at it on the
graph we could say hey where did these
branches come from what was their merge
base or their common ancestor gate gives
you a command to do that it's called git
merge base not surprisingly and it will
tell you the common ancestor and you can
run get merged let's use the standard
git merge it's not the default but it's
the sort of bare-bones it's called
recursive merge instead of resolve I'm
sorry
resolve merge instead of recursive and
it will tell us that we had a conflict
so everything failed there was a
conflict it dumps all that information
about how things change so let's abort
that for a second and let's instead of
running merge base
let's run merge base - - all so again
because of that because master merged
into branch branch merged into master at
the same time we got what's called a
crisscross merge so if we look back in
our graph these two branches now have
two common ancestors so if I run word
get if I run git merge base - - all I
get - so the default situation here what
get tries to do is do that recursive
merge so what it'll actually do is it'll
take these two merge branches and merge
them and then use them as the common
ancestor hence the recursion so it'll
basically just keep going down merging
things into each other and trying to
give you something nice and so before
when we ran the version of merge that
just uses one merge base we had a
conflict when we run with two the the
default it works it works fine because
the merge was made by the recursive
strategy so excellent so recursive merge
is great and it'll totally save you all
of the time right no sadly no and that's
why I tell you that this exists so that
you know how to get out of it and what
to expect when you see it so here I'm on
a different branch sorry a different
repository and if I run git merge branch
again it uses the recursive strategy
everything's fine absolutely no problem
right oh no we had conflicts and holy
did we have conflicts look at this
look at all these merge markers so
what's actually happened here let me get
rid of everything else and we can just
see just the conflict this is one
conflict one line changed right down
here we've got the branch one line up
here we've got had one line in here
this is what we get when we turned on
dip three that is our common ancestor
because get dipped these things you know
it's done the recursive merge it true
goes and finds that we've got two common
ancestors it's going to merge them
together to use as the as the merge base
and they conflict it so when they
conflict get will say well I don't care
about that I'm gonna use it as the merge
base anyway what could possibly go wrong
this is what goes wrong here's how it
could go even more wrong if you had made
the same change somehow in your master
branch and in your other branch that's
not a conflict right but you can start
sneaking in bits of this because this
actually get uses this in the algorithm
this is it doesn't say hey there's a
conflict so we're gonna propagate the
conflict no it doesn't do that it says
here's the merge base go on and usually
when there's a conflict in the merge
base you get a conflict in the result
but not always so you can get you can go
look on github you know go search github
or Google people who have checked in
you know this line temporary merge
branch you'll find it because it's snuck
in this because it didn't propagate that
so hey be careful check your you know to
a build just because it merged to a bill
run your tests sometimes these things
sneak in
so analyze that carefully pretty please
do it for me and you know all your
coworkers right so that's merge in a
nutshell merge is a great great thing I
don't want to start any holy wars
especially not in England when I have a
picture of the American Revolution I
don't want to start any holy wars but
anytime I talk about merge you can't not
talk about rebase and since I told you
how to renormalize and touch every
single file in your git repository to
fix its line endings and then how to
merge things to fix them I would be
remiss not to tell you the same thing
about how to do it with three base
real quickly how does rebase work rebase
works very actually similarly to merge
again if you have some branch master and
some branch branch and you want to
rebase branch on to master if you're on
the branch called branch and you run git
rebase master what happens
well once again get finds that common
ancestor it's there and then get takes
all of the commits that you've made
since that common ancestor and it plucks
them off and puts them on top of that
branch ie this branch is your new base
hence the name rebase here's the tricky
bit about rebase that you might need to
be aware of well there's two kinds of
rebase and one of them is not
interactive that sounds weird because a
lot of people run interactive rebase no
there's two kinds of rebase there's
patch application rebase where in order
to figure out and get these commits over
here it builds patch files for each of
them as if you ran git diff on each you
ran git diff to identity R we're gonna
get diff to isolate the changes here put
them away in a directory switches over
to this branch and starts applying them
one by one that's one way
get rebase works the other way is by
cherry-picking instead it's a subtle
distinction I admit but one of them
involves patch files and running get
apply the other one is get cherry-pick
which uses the merge engine so behind
the scenes it actually runs the merge
code to do that and running the merge
code is good because what happens is
that you can take advantage of all the
things like like the the renormalization
bits that we saw earlier when you are
actually doing the rebase so let's take
a look at that real quickly
there we go right so let me let me clone
down that repository again
[Applause]
great again let me switch to my branch
called branch to which I thank you
apologies let me figure that one out
let's do that
hey all right great
so now I'm on a let me check out branch
two so this is a different branch that
had a full request.open when I did all
that renormalization stuff and I want to
run git rebase master and of course I
get conflicts cuz again all of my lines
changed in the master branch so I need
to update them the interesting thing
about this is you'll see that it started
to do this rebase and it's it's totally
failed and if we actually look at what's
going on in the dot git repository we've
got this directory called rebase apply
which will give you a hint that it's
using the apply mechanism and if I
actually look at what's going on this is
literally a patch file right it was
produced by running git diff and that's
what rebase is doing it's applying these
one by one by one and it doesn't know
how to cope with the fact that you've
changed all those line endings so let's
throw this away
let's get rebase - - abort because we
can instead use read a stash - merge
which uses the lovely merge engine which
does understand how to to handle line
ending changes so we'll we'll do that
and that failed - so what we actually
need to do is give it a little
instruction so let's abort one more time
and what we can do is git rebase - X
just like we did with merge it takes the
- X flag which passes
options to the recursive merge strategy
so I can get rebased - x3 normalize
master and now it's gonna cherry-pick
which is again the merge strategy and
it's gonna pass the renormalize flag so
just like before it's going to forget
about the line ending changes it's going
to apply our changes directly and our
rebase is all done so if I run git log
now I should have a nice linear history
going all the way back down and indeed I
do
the Reds kind of hard to see but it's a
nice straight line like the rebase
advocates in the room like and again I'm
not going to get into a religious
discussion about which of those is
better just that you can indeed take
care of your line endings with both
merge and with rebase great great real
quick
so why is rebase with apply the default
I could not come up with anything I'm I
was I was convinced that there had to be
a reason I stayed up until like 4:00
this morning like banging on this like
surely there's something patch
application can do binary diffs that's
kind of cool
so in theory you could do a rebase with
binaries in your repository and it takes
up a little bit less disk space when you
do that was the best I could come up
with but even that's not true I finally
ended up asking a couple other people
and the answer is there isn't a good
reason they're actually moving towards
making merge the default in rebase so
one of these days you won't necessarily
have to do all these shenanigans to make
rebase a little bit more line anywhere
right so that is really all the time
that we have if you started seeing
graphs and Merkle trees and said I don't
know what's going on but I'd like to
be sure to check out inside get calm
where I have videos of actually diving
into the git repository and and ripping
that open and showing you how that all
works I will also put links to
everything that I talked about with line
and in renormalization so if you have
line inning problems I will have links
to what I just talked about on this site
on my train ride home tonight
so anyway I want to thank you all very
much I really appreciate you guys
hanging out until I want to appreciate
you folks sorry hang out until you know
right bumping up to PubCon if you don't
have tickets for PubCon see if there are
still some available be sure to check
that out and yeah thanks for coming to
NBC London
and I will hang out if you have
questions